-Performing "All She Wanna Do"
from his new album, "Legend,"
once again, John Legend!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ She moves in peculiar ways ♪
♪ This room is nothin' more
than her stage ♪
♪ It's so cruel ♪
♪ The life of the party ♪
♪ She'll be the death of me ♪
♪ I told her, "You're
the love of my night ♪
♪ I won't stop 'til
you're the love of my life ♪
♪ I won't stop 'til you're
the one that I'm takin' home ♪
♪ One I been waitin' for" ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is,
all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do is
get up on her ♪
♪ Got me in
the palm of her hands ♪
♪ All I wanna touch
is her Nirvana ♪
♪ Feels like
I been waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do
is pull her closer ♪
♪ Got me in the palm
of her hands ♪
♪ She don't want
this song to be over ♪
♪ Feels like I been
waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is ♪
♪ Daylight, can't get away from
the flashin' lights ♪
♪ She on the run, tryna
chase that high, yeah ♪
♪ The life of the party ♪
♪ She'll be the death of me ♪
♪ I told her, "You're
the love of my night ♪
♪ I won't stop 'til
you're the love of my life ♪
♪ I won't stop 'til you're
the one that I'm takin' home ♪
♪ One I been waitin' for" ♪
♪ Nooo ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
-♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do
is get up on her ♪
-♪ Got me in
the palm of her hands ♪
♪ All I wanna touch
is her Nirvana ♪
♪ Feels like
I been waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
-♪ Wanna dance, dance, dance,
dance, oh ♪
♪ All she wanna do ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-♪ All she wanna do ♪
♪ Is dance, dance, dance,
dance, yeah ♪
-♪ Yeahhh ♪
-♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do
is get up on her ♪
♪ Got me in the palm
of her hands ♪
♪ All I wanna touch
is her Nirvana ♪
♪ Feels like I been
waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do is
get up on her ♪
♪ Got me in the palm
of her hands ♪
♪ All I wanna touch is
her Nirvana ♪
♪ Feels like I been
waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is dance ♪
♪ All I wanna do is
pull her closer ♪
♪ Got me in the palm
of her hands ♪
♪ She don't want this song
to be over ♪
♪ Feels like I been
waitin' for ♪
♪ Forever and a night
to get this chance ♪
♪ But all she wanna do is ♪
♪ All she wanna do is ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!